hey guys alexa right here i am here with
daniel and evan and we're going to play
this awesome game that you guys are
working on mad max
it's going to be awesome so can you tell
us a little bit about where we are right
now
yeah alexa so
uh right now we're we're pretty far into
the game uh just to give you a little
bit of context we're probably like
two-thirds of the way into the game so
okay evan's had a good chance to roll
through the wasteland and
get the magnum opus fairly dialed into
his liking
and he's on his way right now to this is
a good opportunity to actually show you
kind of uh how far into the game he is
and if you want to back up a little bit
on the camera
this is the wastelands in mad max and if
you wow if you see all that iconography
on the screen right now that gives you a
taste of just how much content there is
to do
in the wasteland this looks intense uh
intense is a pretty a pretty fair
assessment i would say
he so evan's on his way right now to um
a story mission where he is looking for
a racer a registered fighter to join him
so that he can participate
in the gastown races ah
he's see he's after uh he's after a v8
engine to uh equip the magnum opus with
that's going to give him the uh
the boy the speed he needs that's a
that's a random war party that's just
come to uh rain on his parade so
quick the question about the war parties
they're they just appear totally at
random that's right yeah okay there are
some there are different types of combat
that uh max will come across as he's
driving across the wasteland but no
matter where he goes he's probably going
to run into some more boys that are that
are chasing him
just to keep things keep things
interesting keep max on his toes i feel
so bad for chum bucket back there
yeah feels like he's gonna fly off he's
doing fine
the chump bucket has uh that's the path
he has chosen
that's that is the life that he decided
on that's the calling in life do you do
you know much about chum bucket by the
way a little bit but for the people that
are watching right now why don't we wax
poetic and chill okay let's do it yeah
that so that's chum bucket and we meet
him early on in the game he is what's
known as a black finger or a mechanic
and the the mechanic is a pretty hollow
that's my favorite thing to do
yeah and you notice chum buckets he's
actually firing the the uh the harpoon
in the back
i'm out of here but
he's our mechanic anytime we want to
upgrade the magnum opus
chum
he's also kind of like you know max is a
really stoic dude a man of few words so
chum buckets there is kind of a
a source of exposition and comedic foil
he'll point to things around the
environment as you're driving around and
give you some insight on uh set pieces
so he is he's the lens through which we
are experiencing max industry that's a
pretty good way of putting it he's our
he's our guy he's our guy yeah now what
is happening here
uh so this war party is assaulting these
are some of the stink boys some of the
stink boys guys uh
gum stink gum stink gum i i was i was uh
mixing up my terminology
stank gum is a pretty vicious dude in
the mad max world he's he's one of the
top bad guys in the game and his his war
parties are identified by the really
bright
vibrant uh
paint that's on their vehicles let's get
this guy out of there
so uh there's a lot of different ways to
deal with enemies while you're in the
magnum opus
one of them is just through sheer force
and physics based combat you can ram you
can you can grind you have
rims and spikes and all kinds of
different things that you can hit
enemies with
evan will do that right now do it
he's going to try to grind me do it
yeah
you've also got awesome thunder poon
that's the weapon that the evans is the
chum bucket just fired out of the back
of the magnum office that's right run
run
so i could go after him to get strapped
or not
uh he was also he was using the harpoon
too though which is which is my favorite
and i would say probably like
probably the most versatile tool
in the magnus in the magnum opus's uh
repertoire
he can take down objectives in the
environment with the harpoon he can also
systematically dismantle vehicles take
off a tire take off a door and then
after you take off the door you know
what you can get you can pull the driver
right out of the vehicle
that's awesome or you can launch a
thunder poon atom it's up to you
i love that name i do too
i'll probably try to say it as many
times today as i can we'll keep a
running tally
so we are on our way
on a story mission we're looking for a
fighter yeah can you and for a certain
race can you talk a little bit about the
uh
the sort of um like the main quest like
what they'll all have to do with like
we're looking for a fighter now but like
what other things will we encounter
in the wasteland yeah that's a that's a
really good question uh a lot of the
game it has to do with reducing threats
in in the different territories because
scabberous scrotus another name i love
to say gabaris scrotus yeah we can we
just call them scrotus
uh scrotus is is the is the main bad guy
in the game he's established a pretty
tyrannical rain over the wasteland
and as we drive through the wasteland we
meet
we meet different keepers of strongholds
these are fortresses that are ally would
not quite be the way to describe them
but
for all intents and purposes that's a
that's the best way of describing them
you'll meet different allies throughout
the game and in order to further gain uh
their trust and get what max needs which
is typically upgrades for his maximum
opus you're going to have to reduce
threat
in their territories
and reducing threat means uh a wide
number of things taking out uh war
parties and convoy leaders taking out
enemy camps there are numerous types of
camps there are top dog camps which are
kind of like uh that's almost like the
boss fights in the game those are really
big interesting dudes
yeah there's camps full of enemies that
have a really particularly devastating
enemy waiting for max at the end and
then there's also oil pump camps and gas
tank transfer camps so any any of those
things that you do that you overtake is
going to populate those areas with
allies but also lower threat in the game
so you're basically just trying to maybe
not essentially make make peace but just
make sure that nothing hits the fan
while you're on your way that's a good
way of describing it because i don't
think i don't think there's really peace
in the wasteland no matter
how hard we try
so uh codazzle just pointed us over to
the tenderloin this is the last fighter
left
so baxter's gonna go talk to her
she doesn't look too happy
she has uh vitamins
oh oh that's what that is oh okay i was
like what's your breathing i get it now
dazzle calls her a fume head
he describes her problem as sucking the
mask
so when you were naming people like
we've already heard a couple of like
really
silly names like how much fun did you
have naming your weapons naming people
like what did you sort of go to for that
that's a big part of the world right
like it's it's uh it's a sticking point
for mad max everybody's got some crazy
name everything has something like
really memorable
and everything is
multi-syllabic but rolls off the tongue
in a in a really delicate way there's a
really good writer for the game every
everything that chumbucket says
everything that comes out of mad max's
mouth is like just very
mad max breathed and very appropriate
the the writer's name
perfectly is odd
that's his name his name is
wow
and he's uh he's not he's a brilliant
swedish man yeah he's awesome wow
later on
what would your max name be
i should have thought about that
you have until the end of the stream to
think of something
certainly drive shaft drive
because you're always the driver exactly
totally nailed it alex you did an
awesome shadow of murder stream with us
last year
you're you are definitely a good driver
so how about the design like when you
guys were
obviously you're making like very
different like parts of the wasteland i
see this guy's feathers and some people
have like just the tighter clothing and
he is the armor so when you were
designing
mad max what did you where did you get
inspiration from what did you look at
other than
the mad max that has existed in the
world already
i'm mostly still thinking about what i'm
going to name myself okay sorry
but no i think i think that's a that's a
really important design consideration
it's
when when establishing the tropes of
what is what is mad max what is this
universe what does it mean to be uh mad
maxian
it's about cobbling together uh
something that is
like hopefully practical uh all about
survival and using the scrap and
components that are
that are available there's not much as
you can imagine in the wasteland nobody
cares about gold or precious metals the
thing that you are after is scrap metal
what can you turn into armor what can
you turn into a car yeah speaking of
scrap that was a good segue there you go
this is the this is the car that we're
building yeah tell me about the car
because the the car customization is
is the big thing here so let's talk
about the car yeah the magnum opus is a
huge part of the game and what evan's
looking at right now he's been tasked
with building the speed demon because if
he doesn't have this particular build of
magnum opus he's not going to be able to
participate uh in this death race so we
need to participate in the death race to
get rid of tenderloin's debt if we get
rid of her debt she'll fight with us
right
and we need her yeah we have to have her
in order to join the gastown race she's
she's the only registered fighter that
we can get to participate in the gastown
race with us so as we're looking at uh
this archangel you see all the different
things uh that you can outfit on the car
there's armor engine suspension uh flame
pipes harpoon
uh thunder poon flame pipes thunder poon
there you go i got it in there worried i
wasn't going to get it in there
border spikes so driving through the
wasteland when war parties approach you
sometimes there are war boys that jump
from their vehicles to yours
border spikes will put an end to that
real fast
and you can you can see that uh
everything he's looking at also affects
the stats of the vehicle pretty
dramatically from attack to defense
acceleration handling repair speed
exactly you can that that actually
affects chum bucket so if you're able to
upgrade repair speed chum is going to
get armaments and uh tools that he's
equipped with that allow him to repair
the magnum opus quicker and i'm sure
you'll see over the course of this next
hour even though evan's a pro
the uh the opus is gonna take some
damage and you'll see chum rush out to
stand on the hood with an extinguisher
and put out the flames and quickly
wrench up the opus back to health poor
guy i mean he's riding on the back of
his car with no armor just like
hanging out yeah i feel kind of bad for
him i don't know man that's i grew up in
small town texas and that's just kind of
what we do really yeah so maybe the
wastelands like you know texas yeah it's
like texas
this is what we do
riding on the back of cars half closed
yeah throwing things half of half
clothes maybe
oh boy
i want to say that this looks beautiful
but it's not supposed to be beautiful
it's supposed to be sad
the waistline's supposed to be sad but
this is like this is amazing it's
tragically beautiful so if you wanted to
like just like you can just drive across
the whole thing right you can just like
pick a corner and go oh pretty much yeah
in fact you can actually just keep
driving way out into the wasteland and
you'll keep going and the game will keep
generating it really yeah it's an
avalanche thing anything you can see you
can go to and there is no border wow see
i did not
know that whoa okay that's awesome yeah
i mean you might run out into a few
horribly deadly storms out there you
might run into nothing you might run
into a bunch of cliffs and mountains
like
but it will keep going
eventually run out of gas and you'll die
the first thing i'm doing when i get
this game is i'm just gonna drive you
know it's a funny story at gamescom we
had a guy who
was you know you only stand in line for
a long time and you only get you know 15
20 minutes to play yeah and he spent his
time just driving and he had the biggest
smile on his face
i kid you not it was quite charming
driving to the sunset
oh storm approaching so i'm glad i'm
glad this is happening oh no i'm glad
that you me so storms are completely
random in the game okay
we can't we can't trigger them
but i tend i tend to i tend to think
that
avalanches games especially mad max are
ah
i don't know
are most engaging when more is happening
so the more that the more these guys
tend to cram on the screen especially in
terms of particle effects uh i think the
more beautiful and the the more
interesting it looks
oh my god so now this is a lightning
storm
giant lightning bolts are going to be
zapping all around max and the game the
gameplay um
uh hook of the storms is they're really
devastating and they're gonna take you
out if you linger in the storm for too
long
but there are giant crates of loot
called mother loot
oh god i love the naming in this case
and that's how you get so scrap is scrap
is the currency that max is after he
needs he needs scrap to upgrade his own
armor uh but also the magnum opus of
course so the risk reward is if we
linger in the storm we have a chance of
tracking down these crates of scrap
which i'm going to be looking for
he can uh he can escape
the storm if he goes to a stronghold or
an enemy camp that he's taken over
but i'm risking it
oh my god put them on loot do it i
believe you
there's something
so i am looking in looking in the chat
taking questions from people that are
watching and we have a question about
hand-to-hand combat you can beat people
up on the ground yeah you can beat
people up real good real good and i
think i think that's probably what
evan's in route to i think he's on his
way to work
did you get it did you get it you got it
let's see if this lightning doesn't come
what's in it what's in it kick it
so this will give me a lot of scrap here
oh nice wow
oh you got to watch out for the
lightning i don't know
that was really cool he put himself out
stop drop and roll
poor man how about a blue whale
hey guys just hanging out sometimes uh
and so much of the game is persistent
too you'll get into fights with war boys
in a storm and you'll see a debris from
a previous battle
just swirling about in the storm
knocking out people in the fight
uh but so evan's on his way to a camp i
believe i am yeah see that bridge over
there that's actually a camp okay
so he's going to approach his camp and
then and then we'll see how max
uh deals with hand-to-hand combat
that's a lot of loot that is a lot of
loot the last one some lightning blew
away a lot of it so so you would say
that it's sort of lucrative for players
to chance take a chance with the storms
exactly if they can get definitely
luckily this one didn't last too long
it's just kind of finishing up now but
there's some health over here so i'm
going to go towards that
let's play some food truck is just like
okay he's cool he doesn't mean much he's
happy
it's just so funny you know what is this
so food is of course really scarce in
the wasteland let's see what we find
what did we find
oh is it fuel it's like a
lizard some roadkill of some sort
so max is a super tough dude but he's
also you know he's pretty vulnerable
he's not a superhero
he can carry water with him in a canteen
that is a limited
a limited amount of health that he can
recover
or he can find uh he can find dog food
dogs more dead animals oh that was
impossible dude
i've never seen that happen oh my god
yeah they're
they're gonna be okay i'm sure
maybe
is this a this is a stink gum camp that
you're approaching right yes
yes it's not on my map yet so evan's
headed towards a stank gum camp and the
objective in these camps is to eliminate
all the enemies so this is a
particularly
combat heavy camp that he's heading into
so i'm sure we're going to see
the depth and range of max's abilities
here
i want to see him kick people
i do too kick them in the face
this is
this is really like just expansive like
i'm sort of just looking at the
the the how like just wide and like far
everything is and it's sort of
sort of intimidating i'm going to scout
this out real fast because there are
some defenses
flame pipe there's a sniper it's always
to to the players benefit to scout as
max before approaching an enemy camp
so scouting sort of shows you what's
there uncovers what threats might be
waiting for max
because some are long range some some
are not but if you can scout things out
that's going to give you an assessment
of what the threats are
also the the magnum opus is
it's your it's your mobile uh fortress
as well as your means of conveyance so
max can climb in the back bust out a
sniper rifle get zapped by some
lightning from the storm that's still
going no oh god we'll finish up here it
looks like i got out of the sand but
there's still some lightning uh snipers
are a particularly
nasty threat they'll take out max really
quick so he's gonna try to take care of
the snipers before he storms into the
camp oh my god
boom
dude you can nail that crier too from
from here
there's a crier oh yeah
got him wow
the sniper rifle is super effective and
super powerful but ammunition for it can
be pretty scarce
so you have to sort of rash in your yeah
make wise decisions with your ammunition
so a big part
would you say a big part of this game is
sort of resource management in terms of
it is yeah you're not going to be able
to run into a camp and run and gun your
way through it
because you do have a shotgun and it's
really powerful and really effective but
ammunition is also really limited
man this world is just totally screwed
up you can even you can even drive
around in the opus while you're in the
back of it
oh cool chum will floor it for you
i need to get this guy
it's amazing how like quick stuff
changes like one minute like you're
driving and he's on the back and then
lightning hits you when you're out and
you're harpooning someone or sniping
someone like it seems like everything is
designed to just be constantly moving
that's true
it's never really boring there it is
all right and then the flame pipe right
here i'm gonna
weld that up
oh my
there we go i think you're good i also i
can also because i got the mother lode i
have quite a bit of scrap i can use to
upgrade stuff let's do some upgrading so
in order to build the speed demon you
know we don't have the system where more
upgrades is better uh-huh it's just
different so
to make my car faster i need to get rid
of that ram and grill i already got rid
of the spikes
i'm gonna need some uh
shocks ooh
that'll improve my handling
some of these tires
so i just made two upgrades the
suspension of my tires towards the speed
demon so i still need to get rid of my
armor which i'm not gonna do yet
upgrade this exhaust up here which is
gonna be a lot of scrap and i need to
lower threat from five to three in pink
eyes territory
i need to find this car body which is
hidden somewhere in the rekills region
and i need
this uh
brushed metal raw steel paint job and i
need to defeat a top dog in order to
unlock that
top dogs are also your guardians of
car cosmetics so they're the owners of
paint so if you want to change the the
look of uh the magnum opus you're going
to have to deal with top dogs
so he showed you the exhaust and he
showed you that he needs he needs more
scrap to get it but he
also needs to unlock oh that's haunting
uh he also needs to lower the threat
in in the pink eye she's the
she's the she has the stronghold in this
territory he needs to lower the threat
in her region in order to unlock that
piece of exhaust that piece for the opus
from her but by doing this by uh raiding
this camp and and taking care of all the
enemies in it he's gonna he's gonna
lower the threat
oh nice why are they blue
so stank gums boys are the color are the
colorful ones oh so they like paint they
they paint themselves the the war party
that he encountered uh on the way here
earlier
so this for your uh
that blue man group for your for your
fella in the chat that was asking about
hand-to-hand coffee yeah here we go here
we go
right now in theory mode
the longer you can keep your chain
running uh and
he's got a 20 26 hit chain right now
which is more than i've ever been able
to do so the more the more you rack up
the more damage you do
the the longer you get your chain uh the
faster fury is going to build that piece
of iconography in the top right with the
skull and the steering wheel made out of
chain that's the fury meter
and if you can fill that you're going to
enter fury mode which just allows you to
do more damage uh gives you uh more
ability to track to your enemies
basically make you more more capable in
hand-to-hand combat
looting corpses also looks like
a good thing to take it off this is just
so mad max i love it
so this is a stankum camp the goal for
this one is to take out all the fighters
which is 23 for this particular you can
see in this uh thing that i can toggle
well you got eight eight down
a couple more to go down
15 more again
oh my god
of course i'm gonna get the scrap on the
way
nice
oh man where is everyone it's too quiet
i don't like it
i don't like it
so this i think this camp is also a
pretty good example of how vertical the
game can be yeah i was gonna um ask
about the sort of you think of the
wasteland you think you know you're flat
you're just driving around but this is a
lot of
verticality to it yeah and it's and it's
uh definitely along the
uh the tropes of what is
what is uh
how you would build an enemy camp in mad
max it's assembled from
uh a bunch of found things you know like
yeah train cars and there are a lot of
things built out of airplane fuselage in
the in the world and um abandoned ships
so other than that sort of scrappiness
oh no okay i don't have any water this
is going to be hard is water how you
heal
it is yeah yeah there's food too that
you find but water is the no
the canteens are the the only uh
recoverable health that you can take
with you ah that was good you did good
yeah you did good you're real good you
did good appreciate it guys it doesn't
feel bad but other than that scrappiness
you when you say the tropes of mad max
what to you are the tropes of mad max
yeah i mean definitely
making the most of what you have
taking scrap and turning it into
something
something that is built for
endurance and built to dish out damage
so that's what you see that's how
enemies look that's how enemy
encampments are built
everything everything serves a purpose
and that is to
deal damage or withstand damage
nice
so it's just emphasis on oh you respond
right back in the camp yeah camp's up
camps have really uh generous
checkpoints for you so he doesn't have
to fight his way through that first wave
again i noticed the saving icon in the
upper right hand corner
evan's gonna show you a gut shot because
that's my favorite song in the game i'm
gonna get that blue guy show me all the
good stuff he was uh
oh great this guy he's he's kind of
problematic
let's get him
oh
oh that's awesome
get him
wow
that's not the kind of
game oh
shiv punisher
oh okay oh wow you can carry shivs in
your ammo belt
uh but you have a limited number of them
so you're frequently presented with the
opportunity to use them and it's kind of
an immediate way to dispatch an enemy
so you can you can save those or use
them in particularly uh
particularly tough scenarios
oh man so you've got
for weapons you got your shivs any of
your guns
yeah what else and then uh max himself
has his foot he has gauntlets he has
wrist armor he has a bunch of different
things that upgrading max will allow you
to deal more damage take more damage
and his combat his combat is pretty
expansive as far as the progression goes
you have a lot of different moves that
you can unlock you can take weapons from
enemies so weapons of opportunity are a
big part of the game and different camps
will have
different types of enemies that are
holding different types of weapons
which i'm going to pick up right now for
this next wave
yeah that made me thirsty
wait there was scrap in the corner was
there
go back
it was like i'm like so you're thinking
like oh yeah they're thinking like a
wastelander i am so ocd about collecting
stuff in video games it's like you have
to get all of the stuff yeah
this is all this crap this is a great
game for that i i find myself like with
the warframe i'm gonna need to take him
out so this war crier got this guy right
here that's beating the drum uh you see
that piece of hud at the top with the
gauge that's spilling if evan can't take
care of the war crier before that gauge
fills oh no oh look at him okay he's
gonna buff all of these dudes
so once it fills they all get like a
oh they'll get a healthy damage buff
but he was just minding his own business
hanging from the ceiling yeah beating
his drum not bothering anyone and he
killed him
oh my god
wow
so the fury ground execution
uh the the melee weapon execution that
you just saw those are some examples of
how combat has progressed for evan and
max those aren't skills that you have
available at the beginning
you can see there's definitely an
emphasis on crowd control in combat yeah
he's able to take on you know
10 guys or more at a time and still have
a really
um still feel in control
crowd control feels like a very much mad
max thing absolutely just
one guy
versus a bunch of dudes an avalanche is
really elegant about how they build
their control schemes he's doing uh
evan's doing a lot with very little
right now very little input
so i know as a player he doesn't feel
overwhelmed and even like a even a
novice player won't feel overwhelmed
there's a lot of discoverable depth in
the combat so for the players that are
really into that's my favorite oh my
gosh that was so awesome so gnarly right
oh that was so awesome
and when he does that in a in a um
combat scenario and there's a bunch of
dudes around they'll kind of you'll see
they'll kind of back off for a second
they get a little demoralized
you'll have a little window where
nobody's attack after you shoot somebody
in the gut with a sawed-off shotgun the
enemies kind of oh okay all right man
you can just take your stuff and leave
so he just got
down from a five to a four excellent oh
and you can see that uh he's populated
the camp with allies now oh cool allies
have showed up uh and one of the big
benefits of having allies in the camp is
not only can you seek refuge from storms
here now oh nice but you'll get periodic
drops of scrap from them
so as you're driving about in the
wasteland as you're doing
activities you're going to get drops of
scrap from them because now they're on
your side and they're helping max great
so it's it's nice to have friends yeah
it behooves the player to uh max is he's
you know he's a man on a mission for
himself he's he's kind of a selfish dude
ultimately but um
it's to his benefit to help people out
oh
gnarly
oh my gosh
i just keep i keep looking at the when
you're in shots like this i look at all
the mountains in the background you can
go in the perfect blue sky there's gas
town over there whoa
fires yeah avalanche's thing is anything
you can see you can drive to
those mountains you can totally drive to
him
first thing i'm gonna do when i get this
game i'm just gonna drive off into the
sunset
forever and ever and ever forever and
ever and then i'll come back you wanna
do it if you do that you're gonna wanna
do what evan's doing he's he's bringing
gas from the camp back to the opus smart
uh you can store gas in the back of the
opus that's gonna be my next question
how do we store that fuel i'm gonna
refuel first so
oh that's cool
so you can like do you put is there like
a set number of gas cans you can have
back there like how does it work it
looks like i already have one back there
you can see it right there so yeah you
can take one with you exactly
cool and of course you use fuel as you
drive around but evan has flame pipes as
well which is one of the armaments that
you can equip on the magnum opus oh and
that's going to use fuel too oh that's
so cool
that's a great aoe attack so while
you're driving around in a war party or
a convoy which is what evan's going to
show next that's a great way to to
assess like a bunch of enemies again
like crowd control there's crowd control
for the magnum opus as well
the balloon that you see in the distance
uh those are really helpful you can see
a lot of great set pieces like gas town
in the distance and you know that that's
something you should head to
but uh finding an outpost with an uh hot
air balloon that's gonna allow max to go
way i love the harpoon oh my goodness
those are uh scarecrows they're all
throughout the game world and taking
those down is going to lower lower
threat and influence and some are
stronger than others some you need a
certain amount of upgrades or take down
you can ram them down you can use
explosives
oh man
those uh those outposts though the hot
air balloons that's a way to get really
high up in the in the air and no and
locate all the loot locations all of
that oh nice death races all of the
enemy camps you can spot them from afar
and then get a
a better assessment of what activities
there are to do in the world
oh my gosh those dudes are armored so
the little shield with the number tells
you how many layers of armor they have
on but you can take all their armor off
can we flame them oh yeah totally flame
them
oh no let's do it i like the slow-mo
when you crash it's just like
super dramatic right
very dramatic
the opus is so much fun to drive around
and it's it's also really
it's really forgiving
you can take it you can take it anywhere
i'm coming up on this tumblr jump out
roll out
so the uh
there they are the tire marks that evan
found
he found he found this convoy leader
really quick but if he hadn't there are
a lot of uh a lot of great environmental
cues in this game that help you find
your next your next objectives it's got
a giant cloud of dust that's that's
moving around uh to the left of the
screen right now if evan had gone to
investigate that he would have probably
located this convoy
and convoys are really cool so there's a
convoy leader up at the front and
he has a hood ornament there are a
number of hood ornaments that max can
collect in the game
you can see that he actually has one on
his rear bumper right now that skull
yeah those are different passive uh
benefits that max can equip to the
magnum opus uh what do they give you uh
allows him to deal more damage sustain
more damage go faster
you name it uh and he's gonna acquire
those by taking out convoy leaders
so just can we get this guy better
ramming we'll see
i think i have so much faith in you
my car is probably not quite upgraded
enough this is probably one of the more
difficult combos but
i love this music
oh boy
did we get him maybe we heard him
whoa
so my favorite thing to do is
is harpoon the driver right out of the
vehicle but he can't do it to these guys
because they're a little beefed up so
he's got a he's got to drain their armor
a little bit before he can do that now
when you say harpoon you mean thunder
poon right well there's thunder poot and
harpoon so the thunder poon is the uh
that's not the those are the
non-replenishable ones like once he has
the ammunition to manage
the harpoon you can use it just has a
cool down so you can use that as much as
you want you can upgrade it oh this
dude's going to try to build you oh no
oh no oh my gosh
let's see if i can get away we're chumbo
he's uh he's ducking he's oh there he is
there we go i was concerned i was
concerned i could have shotgunned him
off but i want to save my shotgun i'm
very concerned about chumbucket i'm like
a nervous person in general yeah so
having him just like unprotected sitting
on the back of my car makes me really
nervous
that means that means
don't hurt him
oh my gosh
i have so much empathy
i'm so scared he's gonna like fly off
the back or something he does a pretty
good job of hanging on well you saw that
when the border jumped out of the
vehicle he ducked down yeah
oh my god oh that's awesome
oh my gosh
i wish i had a stronger ramen grill
oh
damn
so worried about him falling off he
can't fall off the right no okay all
right i feel i feel much better
you'll be barreling through the air like
spinning 360 degrees and chum is just
hanging on it's got the grip of an
orangutan oh my god actually he loves it
like he'll
he loves it he'll say crazy things while
you're flying through the air like we've
got wings
oh my god
oh
there's a leader here this is the big
fuel truck there
now if you take him out
you get his hood ornament that's right
what else do you get uh scrap scrap
uh and you lower threat in the territory
that's why i'm doing this
nice
get up
you're doing pretty good dude you're
doing a lot better than i would do
oh my god
this guy's a fuel can on the back of his
car so i can rip his armor off
i love the flames the flame oh there's
no shortage of flames involved let's
play him a little bit more here do it
yay
oh that's awesome
so
oh yeah
let's see if i can get this guy yeah
oh you got my desk
that's what the board spikes are for
jumped onto the spikes did you see that
yep
oh that's
i was playing this i was playing this
the other night and oh no there's more i
played so much in this game but i'm
always seeing new stuff i was outside of
my car doing combat to a war party that
had assaulted me
and i punched a dude against my magnum
opus and he got
he died getting thrown into the spikes
on my car oh boy i was it sounds kind of
sadistic but i was so happy to see that
like those little surprises that you see
in avalanche games like they've really
thought about all the all the possible
situations that could have happened and
they've really done a great job of
accounting for it yeah it seems like it
seems like you really
like when people say oh a game's open
world and you can do whatever you want
like i really feel like this is just
like
go like you are mad max you do what you
have you got to do yeah and you do it
your way and i i always talk about how
like i think avalanche does a really
good job of giving the player a toolkit
full of devices that are just kind of
all-purpose and are going to really
whatever situation
you are up against the tools max has are
are perfectly equipped for that
especially the harpoon i think it's like
super versatile you can do so much crazy
stuff with it oh no that guy just hit a
wall i was like that was awesome that
happens too you'll see enemies take
themselves out uh friendly fire is on so
they'll they'll wreck each other too oh
man
that's right the scrotus faction
oh my gosh
oh my god please don't fall out i know
you said he can't fall out but i am
still concerned
he's just like hanging out he's just
holding on
oh my god
this guy's
grinding rims on
it's gonna be a little bit harder to
take him out
oh my gosh that guy's got a lot of
oh oh crap oh no oh no wait a minute
what's going to happen
it's cool if i get out
where's chum bucket where's he oh my god
all right so concerned so concerned for
trouble so he'll scramble to the the
hood of the car and put out the fire and
and get you back on the road so what
what would have happened if we didn't
get out uh death that death would happen
you'd explode
oh poor guy
he loves what he does it's cool i can
catch back up you say it's cool but i'm
still concerned
and then he'll i love his little
animation as he scrambles to the back
yeah
okay
i lost some of my map but i can catch my
cup
oh my god
and then not
not only is he
chasing down the convoy leader but it
looks like a random war party has
spawned oh my god and now so now there
are more dudes they're old
they're just like a party so we call a
meat wagon there's a bunch of borders
meat wagon
i like it
i think that might have to be
i might have to fold that into my mad
max name somehow i don't know
meat wagon to me sounds like what sounds
a little appetizing
so i wouldn't like yes i would like a
wagon full of meat but if you mean like
people that are
yeah
maybe that's that's a food truck
wagon a mad max themed food truck called
me wagon
there you go free marketing you guys can
have that one for free thank you i mean
i'll phone headquarters after this the
meat wagon come to the meat
a cup of sand
you throw it in your face right before
you eat did homeboy regenerate health
no no
he did acquire a couple more guys though
ken uh uh if you are working like say
you're working at these guys you get
them down to one armor and then they
leave do they regenerate
health if you don't
keep at it or are they just like done
they do not regenerate health but
this guy as you can see has uh acquired
a couple more guys since uh yeah okay
since he got a little bit far ahead of
me
but only a couple
still should be able to take him out
you're doing ooh
gotta rip off a couple things of armor
that harpoon is so cool
back to how
i feel like
i feel like avalanche really understands
like the there's an emphasis emphasis on
letting the player do a lot without
really without really taxing them uh
with controller acrobatics so he's he's
driving dudes off the road he's chasing
after a convoy leader he's throwing
weapons out of the back of the vehicle
he's firing a shotgun using a harpoon
yeah and he's still able to drive pretty
you know pretty well reasonably well
yeah this whole thing feels really just
feels really smooth like you have tools
to do a lot yeah without having to worry
about like oh you know
and without having to be just like a
super boss some people are really good
at driving games some people are not and
i feel like i feel like
mad max strikes a really good balance of
letting you feel
a really satisfying driving experience
without having to be a dedicated
uh driving game player yeah racing game
player yeah i'm horrible at racing games
like driving into walls flipping off of
scenery that i shouldn't have shouldn't
be flipping off of well driving into
walls and flipping off of scenery what
this is about yeah yes
what is the
the the cracks on top of the screen
i just noticed those does that mean
you've taken damage that's yeah that's
just a little a little visual indicator
that the the opus is uh
not in tip-top shape that's really
that's really clever
and you can get it
no
there are flames around the uh
around the around the screen now too oh
boy
i love that the texas just like get out
of the vehicle get out my car's not
quite powerful enough to take down this
convoy and i ran out of shotgun ammo
which i needed to explode some of those
fuel tanks so i don't think i'm gonna be
able to take this guy out and you're out
of juice too right
i'm gonna be luckily i have this in the
back so some of those guys are super
tough at least yeah yeah this is uh this
is not the the easiest convoy battle in
the game and he's actually doing a
really good job look at that stubble
good job with this double you know what
it's double right it's a double tackle i
think it's a double take i'm actually
gonna upgrade his beard tomb raider has
a hair you guys have stubble oh let's
i'm glad you brought that up because
evan's gonna show you oh boy i was gonna
show you oh my god this is double tech
oh my god head upgrades so you can go uh
you know
nice uh hipster beard yeah or you can go
full blown swedish beard
oh my god oh my god oh my god this is
this is how i prefer to max
oh my god
oh my gosh it's so good
it's so good
i have such beard on me yeah i really
wish i want like a majestic dwarven
beard that i can like braid and stuff me
too i wish i can't this is i haven't
shaved in two weeks
so in order to uh
link through max yeah exactly
this
paint job we're gonna take down a top
dog called rimjabbi wait what's his name
rim jaby rim job
i think he is over
here
rim joby that's him rim jobby
oh my gosh so there's there is fast
travel yeah why would you want to do
that when you can ride around in your
car and everything that's so cool fast
travel is too only the outpost that you
have oh so it's like outpost exactly
those air balloons that we were talking
about earlier those are the outposts
nice
that is that was good to know although i
really enjoy the driving
the driving aspect seems really
enjoyable yeah
in the interest of uh
showing you guys more on this live
stream yeah we've got a little bit more
time
would love to see meet mr rim jaby i
think i think we'll get that chance mr
rjabi
there's so many different icons there's
so much stuff happening here yeah
there's a lot there one one of the icons
we saw it looked like a kind of like a
little ghost that's uh where we can go
meet griffa
he's our our mystic uh
uh guide that when we get griffith
tokens which we can get a in a number of
ways in the world we can increase max's
legend so longevity his ability to take
damage uh volition his ability to get
more scrap when he when he gets scrapped
from a loot location
his ability to use melee weapons more
effectively in combat use fuel more
sparingly get more energy from the food
that he finds in the wasteland and we
get these griffith tokens by doing any
number of these particular challenges as
you can see i have 13 in the bottom
right
and that's my level
right up above it and i know to grow up
certain levels in order to unlock
upgrades for max so he's a sand king
right now right now on his way to road
one level five oh man
day lizard
and uh so those objectives that evan was
showing you
you can go after those things if you
want and you can make that your goal in
the game but just by playing the game
those those objectives are gonna
continuously organically unlock okay
just from participating in the game
driving around driving far enough
looting enough taking out enough enemies
you're going to be constantly leveling
up so the game throws enough at you that
you won't need to like grind per se
right sort of are naturally becoming but
you can if you need to grow up levels
which you there are certain points in
the game that you do then you can
actually find those objectives and go
after them deliberately and do it faster
slow motion for me
ah it stopped working
rhett lowered good job and there's
there's scrap available from taking down
a scarecrow pretty you know anything you
destroy you're gonna get scrap from okay
so here's here's rim jaby's camp
and he's going to scout from afar i
think a sniper may have already seen me
so sniper rifle or binoculars are going
to do a good job of identifying all the
threats oh nice so you just do like a
sweep and then everything will pop up
yeah [ __ ] he did see me oh no
you just gonna drive in there
doing alive
the world zigzagging
oh man so he's just charging in you can
you can be really um
careful if you want and you can take out
all these threat threats from afar with
the sniper rifle most of them
or you can just drive in like
like a boss like evan is doing and take
out everything before the oh man that
hud up at the top that says camp alerted
if that is phil's before he has taken
out all of the perimeter defenses
uh
it's gonna get crazy
especially with these things right here
these molotov slings that are just
launching
those are gonna their fire rate is gonna
uh radically increase and they're just
gonna start lobbing
volleys of flames at max oh my god
fling him oh get him yeah
haha oh man oh damn that sniper's about
to kill him uh the sniper can shoot max
while he's in the car see i'm gonna be
real careful with those guys
gotta avoid him
okay so
jumbo
the camp has been alerted
and uh
and now there's i think there's one
there's another molotov sling still and
it's it's i think that's a fire pipe
okay
fire pipe
oh boy i'm gonna take out this oh boy
the fire pipes just limit max's access
to the cam not ammo oh no
you can poo it dude i think i can put it
thunder punit
that flame thrower he has to disable its
uh
it's fuel source otherwise he can't
enter the camp oh boy
oh we missed it
it's a very hard opponent
oh my god i gotta go around this time
i'm really close and not being able to
take out all those guys
yay
awesome got it
so now the all the perimeter defenses
are down the snipers are down
cool we can get through this gate in any
number of ways i'm gonna drink some
water
who knows what's on the other side
so are there evil uh so will every uh
fortress that you come across have like
defenses that you have to break down
before you can get in there
most definitely some more than others
yeah some more than others for sure this
was a pretty heavily armed one i feel
i love the kick animation i love the
beard i love the beard too
we don't have enough we don't have
enough bearded heroes or
anti-heroes and games i feel
like
uh this is my favorite weapon i know i
know i was fond of the gut shot earlier
but uh i'm gonna go ahead and say this
is my favorite way to kill a guy
oh oh boy
those are thunder sticks they're kind of
like uh that's a thunder poon that we
can find in enemy encampments
so i am
looking at the chat if you guys have any
questions drop them in we will answer
them before we go we have a question
about the car customizations which we
were talking about earlier uh the the
volume
of car customization is astounding you
were saying there's hundreds of parts i
don't know if there's hundreds apart
there's a lot of parts a lot of parts
yeah i mean definitely thousands and
thousands of combinations thousands and
thousands of combinations and there's a
big emphasis on uh
you know we really want the player to
get in there and find what works for
them and the archangels are a really
good way to discover that you can take
any enemy vehicle by the way and add it
to your collection and those are going
to have different attributes for the
player to explore and drive across the
wasteland with but the archangels
the speed demon which he's trying to
build right now of course you can
imagine is not very armored but
incredibly spry there are other
configurations as well that are
much more geared towards armor and
towards dishing out physical damage
which i'll show you guys
so here's all the different uh archangel
loadouts
the uh
argent cavalier is really heavily
armored but it doesn't have a
particularly fast maneuverable kind of
uh way about it you can see all the
stats on the right side
yeah i like pink i like i like that one
a lot just because uh
i'm not good at roads
so pretty
so it's particularly rewarding to take
that one off-road
all right someone a very important
question can you make max be bald
is it an option you can put a do rag on
his head you can put a do-rag on his
head he can wear goggles do-rag is
basically bald he gets uh face paint
dubag goggles beard
short hair long hair oh i don't have
nice
ammo oh
i might just have to fight with this
board cryer so he can't do his thing he
doesn't have ammo to take out the war
cryer there's there's always a couple
ways of doing something so even though
he doesn't have a shotgun to take the
war crier out the war crier is hoisted
by a crane
and if max can
locate the the crane controls
he can drop the crane and lower the war
crier
interesting uh interesting question
about story is there a story for you to
complete or is it a never-ending open
world sort of a question about the
content in the game there is there is
definitely a story uh that's what we're
doing right now story max is a tormented
man and he wants to escape across the
plains of silence in order to do that he
needs to he needs the right vehicle to
do it his car is just not capable enough
of getting him where he wants to go so
he's building the the machine that's
going to help him flee his nightmares
oh we don't really know if the planet of
silence are a real place or if that's a
place in his mind
he's really trying to silence kind of uh
the madness but you know we kind of go
more into that in the game and you'll
have to find out when you play the story
but for right now he wants that he wants
a v8 engine to put in the
uh to put in the magnum opus and then
he's all about his car that's what this
story mission is about he is really a
single-minded dude it's he's in it for
him and he's looking for the car
components that he needs and a lot of
people will ask favors max because he's
a capable tough dude and he'll do it if
there's something in it for him and
fortunately there often is
so he's sort of like the
the i don't want to say the reluctant
hero but sort of
that's yeah he's i mean he's he's
definitely an anti-hero
does it even exist now
um we'll find this man
so of all the stuff there's a lot of
stuff in this game the car max beards
beards all of that stuff
mostly beards mostly mostly the beards
what for for you guys personally what is
your favorite part what is the one thing
that you're just like this is the best
thing ever
well he's he's almost too rim jobby
which is
i'm a huge combat guy i love combat uh
i love i love a really gratifying um
vicious combat especially and i love
crowd control so i love the ability to
get into big fights and feel like i'm
capable or more than capable of handling
the the situation so
oh man
i mean for me it's definitely that uh
you know this is an extremely
physics-based world you know avalanche
is really really good at that and it is
literally different every time our
innovation in this is physics-based
vehicle combat and
no two battles are ever the same and you
know i've been playing this game for who
knows how long yeah who knows how many
times and i still have a blast playing
it
now when you're changing his beard you
can change his clothes too right you can
add
yeah so take a look at his gauntlets
that are prominently prominently focused
right now uh max starts with nothing on
his hands and as you gather more scrap
and level up more by talking to griffa
and exchanging griffith tokens for
legend attributes
max is going to get
different jackets
different his ammo belt is going to
change so he's going to be able to carry
more capacity in ammo and that's
reflected in max's clothing
uh and then the the wrist armor and the
gauntlets are gonna change pretty
dramatically i think this configuration
right now has a solid config he's got
like yeah there are nuts and bolts that
are that are attached to just create a
totally painful
combination of gear he's got one later
on that has wrenches attached to it like
claws oh man
people are asking a lot of people are
asking if you can knock people off off
of stuff like throw them
throw them over ledges or kick them off
oh yeah that's a back-a-box feature
right there yeah
knock dudes off stuff yeah there's
plenty of that you heard it here guys
knocking dudes off stuff major gameplay
feature no this is rim jotting this is
rim jobby and this is i think this is
probably like a great i know we're
about to run out of time so this is a
really great way to wrap it up this is a
boss fight yeah this is kind of like a
mini boss yeah kind of like a mini boss
and uh this guy's gonna give us the
paint we need to uh build the speed
demon once we once we take him out nice
can you kick him off you probably can't
get him off the tower you can lure him
into flames so like i was saying um
friendly fire is always on if something
looks like it hurts it does
rim jaby
and there are a number of other top dogs
that will bring out uh waves of grunts
with them and you see they're making
those massive like area of of effect
attacks he's swinging that giant mace of
his around if there were enemy dudes
around here he'd be killing them all
he'd be knocking dudes off stuff
oh my god
this is intense so you can actually lure
him into the flames over there yeah
he has a charge attack so if you stand
in front of the flames and then lunge
out of the way at the right time
yeah he's going to eat it right here oh
man oh my god oh my god
oh oh i didn't quite make it but you can
knock him into it boom got it oh my
goodness
get him get him you can also make him a
pincushion by just continuously oh my
god oh my god nicely done
brutal
brutal nicely done you did it so he got
his paint uh he's got an ally camp now
that's gonna generate scrap for him and
he also has lower threat in the
territory so wow by doing that one thing
he's actually uh unlocked all kinds of
stuff this is actually a different
territory not the one we're going for oh
it's still helpful still helpful yeah
but you got a body color threats lowered
gut gut gash another nice name yeah so
before we wrap up what is your mad max
name uh daggery didgeridoo daggery dude
yeah i like it what about you
what about you drive shaft drive shaft
drive shot driveshaft and dagger
didgeridoo evan and daniel thank you so
much for stopping by thank you and
showing us mad max out on september 1st
which is in like two weeks two weeks
it's close pre-order now thanks for
watching guys for all of your mad max
news stay tuned to gamespot.com bye
you